the moon bot is a multi-platform  storytelling company a lot of the  mediums we use involve 3d animation  Google cloud platform allows us to  augment our local on-premise render farm  to make sure that we're always able to  render whatever render load is on a farm  in a an efficient amount of time we  worked on a project last year called  taking flight a lot of the scenes  involves a lot of render time to compute  so the cloud enabled us to shrink the  wait time that we have to do on the  compute and we could use both our local  compute capabilities as well as the  cloud to render everything at much  shorter amount of time which thus  allowed our creative team to produce  better results as we take on new and  bigger challenges at moon by it's really  reassuring to know that we have the  Google cloud platform suite of tools and  services as well as partner technologies  such as a veer that can able us to  achieve anything we can dream